yes we are live hello and welcome
to kind july conversations number two
my name is jane hutchin and in a moment
i'm going to introduce you to our
fabulous
guest the mathematics teacher and
advisor
eddie wu but before i bring eddie on
i just wanted to say a big hello and a
warm welcome to you wherever you are
please talk to me on the chat there's a
function there's a tab there tell me
where
your you you are at this time and how
are you doing
um i'm really excited about this
conversation and just to let you know
how we're going to work so from now for
about the next
30 minutes i'm going to be doing this
sort of q a thing with eddie
and then um we're going to throw open
the field to you guys and you are very
welcome to ask eddie
questions and there is a q and a tab
which i think you might be able to see
on the screen in front of you
that is what i want you to use if you
are going to
ask um eddie a question
hi to you jerry and hello to everyone
without further ado
oh i don't even know where to start in
terms of introducing
eddie wu he's obviously the founder and
creator of
youtube he was australia's local hero in
the australian of the year awards 2018
he's one of the top 10 teachers as
announced by the global teachers
prize hi vicky hi all of you
let's without further ado bring on eddie
hi eddie good evening jane and to
everybody thank you so much for having
me
i'm so looking forward to this chat it's
so
lovely to see you eddie you always look
really happy
do you feel as happy as you look um
that's a good question because in some
ways i don't know how happy
i look but i do know one thing which is
that especially
now speaking with you but i all the time
we all have so many reasons i think to
be happy and grateful
about the things that are going on in
our lives in the world around us even
when there are
some troubling and difficult things like
say this global pandemic that we are all
living through
even in the midst of that um i find
there's always a silver lining that you
can focus on and that's what i think i'm
thinking about
hopefully when you're seeing me smile
toward the camera
that's great to hear and i have to say
i'm very excited because we've got one
caller from india
neha i think she's called it's lovely to
hear that we've got
fans far and wide across this globe as
we well know
and also people in perth hello to you
too
i don't want to leave anybody out here
eddie
i've got this list it's a list of
treating people with kindness that a guy
called leo
balbauta who runs i think it's zen
habits a blog
and all of our guests have added to this
i want to read it out to you
um and then i'd like to hear how you
would
add value add to that list so we've got
be friendly be helpful listen
stop criticizing don't control
others i like that one rise above
retaliation
be courteous in traffic i like that one
too
be the change just say hello that was
from
um mrs hurley the governor general's
wife
be slow to judge that was from the
governor general
be considerate of others i gave him two
because he's a pretty important
guy and grace tame our guest
from last week said be patient
what would you put on that list eddie
wow jane i mean that is a pretty
impressive and comprehensive list i
think
probably the thing that rises to the top
of my mind is
forgiveness i think maybe the phrase i'd
put on there is to forgive
abundantly because you know we are all
each of us
um fragile and imperfect human beings we
all make mistakes
um sometimes we hurt the people whom we
love actually i think the people whom we
love
are often the people who we hurt most
because they're close to us and
they trust us and there's such a an
intimacy there
that they're often the people who we
sometimes rub up the wrong way
and i guess forgiveness is in my mind
because without forgiveness
kindness ends uh you know because we are
all going to
collide with each other in some way
shape or form over the course of time so
i think that's why forgiveness is at the
front of my mind
i love that that's a great addition
thank you so much
eddie i wonder we some of us i know you
and me we're in
lockdown and and many people who are
listening to this call might be in
lockdown
i wonder is there a time in your life
when you've thought most deeply about
kindness there's been a few different
occasions i think throughout my life
where kindness
as as a concept as something which is
meaningful to me
personally has come into my life uh
probably the one that
is really the strongest memory that i
can think of
is the time when i was in early primary
school
i didn't have a fun time as a young boy
at school i have an older brother and an
older sister and
my older sister who's five years older
than me um there was a very small
overlap where i just started
you know kindergarten in year one and
she was up there in in the big leagues
with the other big kids
but shortly after that when she left i
remember being quite
lonely in primary school being quite
young
not feeling very much alike the people
around me
and so that was a time when i i think i
was thinking about kindness because
my experience often with my peers was
not
kindness i don't make friends easily i
know this is a bit surprising to some
people but i'm actually a classic
introvert
so it takes me a long time to warm up to
people personally
uh and and to trust them and certainly
if you went back to
seven or eight year old eddie he was not
very good
at making friends um and was sort of
desperate
to receive kindness from people and and
didn't know how to do that so
i think that that's a period of my life
the last many years that's
uh had a deep impact on the kind of
person i am now
and especially the kind of teacher i am
now because young people
um they are my work and the thing that i
love going to school for
every day i want to talk a bit about
your students in a moment
but i want to ask you so i'm guessing
you felt a bit of an outsider
as a young person absolutely i mean
outside is probably the perfect word i
might not have had the presence of mind
to articulate it that way
back when i was that little but i sort
of
definitely knew that i didn't quite fit
in wherever i went
i'll give you a really short example um
you know i was born in australia and
i've lived here my
entire life but i have a face that
certainly
in the early 90s was one that sort of
was looked at with suspicion
and you know my surname it's kind of
like where does that come from what does
that mean
and there were very few people that i
grew up around who i could say oh
they're just like
i am um but that's not just my
experience here on the very few
occasions when i went back to malaysia
which is where my parents were born
and that all of their family is there
i'd go there
and i could blend in so long as i didn't
open my mouth because i can't speak
cantonese which was my parents main
language fluently
and so as soon as i would say anything
to anyone it was kind of like
look at that foreign he doesn't belong
here and so there was this
kind of alienation that i felt and a
lack of belonging
everywhere um and i think sort of
processing that and understanding that
kindness
sometimes means often it means reaching
out to those people who are unlike us
um and showing them care and sympathy
and empathy
um that's why that's that period of my
life it's sort of
kindness was really important to me then
eddie i know
you have spoken about um bullying that
took place
when you were a kid particularly when
you were a young kid
and kids always well not always
but a lot of times kids can do mean
things to
other kids i wonder have you ever had an
opportunity to meet some of the kids who
weren't really
kind to you have you have you been able
to meet them as
adults i wonder yeah actually not a huge
number of times
um but uh you know because obviously
especially from a young age people sort
of diverge and go to all different
places
around the country around the world but
there have been a few opportunities i
actually remember
a few years back someone who um
made life particularly difficult for me
when i was sort of in
year three year four i actually very
distinctly remember
someone coming to the school where i'm
currently teaching
and they were a new teacher they were
substituting for someone who was sick
and i didn't recognize them but i
thought that name
it sounds familiar and as i was walking
past the staff common room sure enough i
saw them
signing in and i thought i know who that
is this is someone
from you know a long time ago probably
wouldn't recognize me i look a little
bit different from back then
and it was quite strange actually um
it's sort of
that the interaction that i had with
with this person
um it was cordial it was uh pretty you
know
polite and courteous and it sort of
dawned on me as i went away from that
interaction that
probably this person had little to no
memory
of who i was back then perhaps the way
they treated me
i don't know that necessarily like you
said children can often
be cruel or mean but not always
maliciously sometimes they just don't
know
what impact their words or actions can
have on the people around them